le collège de montgaillard à saint-denis
remet en place le projet dans son
ensemble une semaine de festival
consacré à deux thèmes tout d'abord la
danse
elle est également la lutte contre les
stéréotypes sexistes programme trois
grands types d'ateliers apprendre aux
élèves les pratiques de la danse est de
les sensibiliser sur les stéréotypes
sexistes grâce à un débat interactif et
montre aux jeunes des productions
artistiques question dans le film l'un
masculin alors ce projet en fait est un
projet donc sur contout qui lui vite à
lutter contre les stéréotypes sexistes
en milieu scolaire voilà par rapport à
un appel à projet qui a été fait en fait
l'année dernière par le fonds
d'expérimentation jeunesse
voilà donc qu'il ya eu tout un travail
qui a été fait donc de rédaction du
projet pour pouvoir lutter contre ces
stéréotypes par la danse l'utilisation
de la danse comment on peut utiliser la
danse pour faire travailler les filles
et les garçons ensemble et pour
construire une relation fondée sur le
respect mutuel entre les filles et les
garçons
plusieurs intervenants ont répondu
présent au projet des professionnels de
la danse qui ont animé divers ateliers
les élèves ont pu apprendre le rock le
lindy hop la salsa le west coast et bien
d'autres encore je fais le cours de
danse pendant le d'école normale mans
vendredi et on a fait déjà
ateliers pendant cette semaine donc les
élèves et danses ont encore et tout ça
et on aime bien danser faire danser tout
les élèves
les petits et tout ça parce que c'est le
prochaine génération
c'est un jeu entre deux partenaires
c'est une danse qui se danse en couple
en général donc on s'amuse on essaie de
faire rire l'autre et l'autre essaie de
faire la même chose donc on prend
beaucoup de plaisir à danser là dessus
donc je pense que ça devrait plaire aux
jeunes de collège oui on est d'accrocher
celle puisque comme issue d'une danse
qui est quand même assez sportive et pas
très comment dire pas très stricte sur
les amuse c'est sympa en plus de la
danse les élèves du collège de
montgaillard ont participé à des
ateliers animés par l'association
chancégal une association qui défend
l'égalité des chances entre les femmes
et les hommes dans le monde
professionnel
moi je propose aux élèves de répondre
d'abord à deux questions début de
l'activité qui sont calmées tirer vrai
tu de faire dans l'avenir de façon
ouverte et qu'elle mais tirait vrai tu
de faire si tu étais du sexe opposé
et bien souvent on observe que les
jeunes en fait donne une réponse
vraiment en lien avec des stéréotypes
très présent dans la société donc pour
ce qui est des métiers dits d'hommes et
des métiers dits deux femmes plutôt
réservé sommes plutôt réservés aux
femmes et le but de cette activité là
pendant une petite demi heure c'est de
les faire réfléchir
sur et de les amener à une ouverture là
se rendre compte qu aujourd'hui une
fille vraiment aller vers l'orientation
et le métier qu'elle veut et un gars au
également sans se fermer de portes se
fermaient de filières professionnelles
instaurée aux collégiens des règles du
vivre ensemble et faire disparaître les
clichés et les stéréotypes sexistes
c'est le but du projet dans son ensemble
qui durera deux ans